okay for people joining our livestream
this is the the next and kind of a
marathon series of meetings today about
functions for the upcoming version of
woven language so here are a bunch of
functions that are kind of connectivity
layer functions and starting with start
web session and we are looking at
documentation and reviewing these so let
me see what happens here so this is
going to start a different instance
right and so if I go here um and I say
why I say for example web execute of
open this isn't Auto completing by the
way okay
um that should be Auto completing right
um is it open page arrow this right I
don't have to say the HTTP okay so we
should probably not require that yeah
can we can we figure that out please
yeah
okay so somewhat bizarrely it showed the
Chrome browser come up temporarily as it
did that right yeah because it was
single sort execution as you suggested
that's what that that's doing one-shot
execution so is this so this is not
creating a session so if I say if you
status listen if I say get page is that
the is that the no you if I start a
session called started system okay why
is it saying dollar failed rather than a
failure object okay I'd include that
okay great
do we know if the version 12 build is
clean enough that I can use this okay so
let's go all right so web execute is
one-shot execution by default it's that
correct so so what I should thing um
okay exa gauge we shouldn't say execute
that command in a web browser or
something
execute the command wait a minute is
this right because this isn't doing it
it's a one-shot thing right is that
correct that it's a one-shot thing if
there isn't a current web search if
there isn't a current web session that's
great okay so we need to document that a
little bit more carefully though you
didn't it would have been nice if you
know the correct formatting by the way
somebody is growling into the microphone
if you could fix that up a great
haha
so you mentioned updating so some of
these elements here well I'm saying this
here you want to say execute the command
in a web-browser basically
that's what we should say here and we
should say execute list of commands in
sequence
and it returns the result from the last
one
correct I think right now it returns a
list of results but we have to be clear
on what it's doing so that's fine if
that's what you want to do that's okay
but we have to document at writin right
okay okay
web execute of commands
duh execute
it's the commands in a which we say one
shot web browser session if No
say first if dollar current if I think
we have a similar comments to blow that
I know we do I know we do I think it's
but I think it's a little unclear what's
gonna happen here
a let's see I think we should say at the
beginning here web executes effectively
it executes a web driver it is that what
we want to call it
why isn't web okay that's stupid web
driver come on
well whatever I think think that should
not be driver on its own um
okay in any case um we should say
something about how it executes a
through a webdriver how would we say
that
do you understand my question so whoever
this executes maybe uses webdriver to
interact with the browser what is the
technical terminology what is the
technical thing we're saying here it's a
little bit but just say what you would
say technically just give me the precise
technical description it's kind of like
an executable or server so maybe these
launches or executes just say what you
would say in the most technical
description of what this is doing its
what is web what is the role of what
role is imbue don't have a lot of time
so we have got to get through this
fairly quickly I think it interacts with
your browser okay okay um execute
commands in a web browser through a web
driver is that right I think so yes okay
commands if
if acre if a web session has been
started
went through it with
start web session right yes web executor
commands execute Kumar execute commands
in that session
as Yousef I'd buy dollar current web
session if a no web session has been
started web execute of commands starts a
web session execute the commands then
ends the web session um web execute so
where do we say that what it returns
limit
we have some oh yeah okay so this isn't
the correct thing okay so so hold on
okay WebEx
obsession
okay so now we have to say web execute
of command
you
I think we want to say returns either
the output of the command or a
successful failure object
um web execute our of CMD 172 etc
returns a list of results for each of
the list of results for the list of the
results list of the results for the CMD
I right make sense
yes yep crying
you
okay sports the following
to webpages related to complete webpages
upon the specified webpage get the URL
of the current web page page title get
the title navigate to the previous
do we say navigate to or just go to the
previous I think go to because I don't
know what navigation means I sense to me
[Music]
by the way somebody is asking about
support for other languages and external
evaluators including Julia yes it is
coming I don't know is that gonna be
there for 12 oh I don't think we'll have
that for 12 oh we're looking at a lot of
languages right now though all right so
but kind of finishing that fruit
although is a little bit too soon yeah
but it will be in fact Pacolet updatable
right so it'll be will probably arrive
fairly quickly thereafter correct yeah
we could do that
okay
some was asking with this functionality
allow one to automatically test websites
with JavaScript like selenium yes that
is the point we've been using this stuff
internally for a long time things like
this so actually let me just check one
thing so the the thing that says we have
web image right that's why is that still
showing up in that weird context that's
not right
that this we have and this is built-in
now right yeah okay did we um it's
documented right I documented I don't
think that was yet well so we need to
document that yeah okay so wait a minute
was that on the list I didn't see that
on the list for twelve oh so okay so
that's something we're gonna need here
okay so let's see
um captures because it gives an image of
the webpage
specified that's why by URL is that it
is that the art but there must be a
bunch of options to this rate about ping
times and God knows what else right you
know we have discussed about that but
the basic person is implemented and the
next options will be keep updated we
have not yet come up with many options
but we have discussed some so so for
example of Education is certainly an
option to have yeah that's what you say
yes sir
okay okay so authentication certainly
something
okay so this is also URL execute
probably URL execute and rasterize are
two things which this needs to point to
etc okay so this needs to clearly web
execute needs to point to web image
you
um okay alright let's go on with this
now okay so let's go on with these
things here so let me let me look at so
if I say locate elements so for example
let's go to our home page so by the way
we agree this should return a failure
object right and that failure object I
why isn't this generation error message
that says web execute has been has been
asked to do a command that doesn't know
it should do that right yeah yeah that
makes sense
okay okay so if I say start web session
the start web session have an argument
or not why does it keep on saying it's
in the web unit
why does it keep on saying it's okay now
why do I have this window up here do I
need to keep that window what happens if
I close that window well that is the
session so most things will be done in
that window so if you navigate to
webpages it'll show you but if I close
that window I'm screwed yes or no yes
yeah okay so we do we say that in the by
the way this needs to be a documentary
and some kind of workflow thing okay
starts a web session and returns a web
session object okay okay creates a web
session okay start web session on on an
interactive so um start web session
we'll typically bring up a web browser
window on the screen our commands in the
web session will be executed with
respect to this window it's that right
yep that's accurate
okay we're still going away tonight if I
say visible as false then that see them
that's not only images doing this it is
doing in visible false mood
it's a headless session so there's no
graphical okay by default we'll bring up
a web browser screen will bring up a
visible web browser screen so we come on
the web session will then be executed
with respect to this window will then be
be executed visibly in this window that
fair way to say it yeah yep
now is there a single window or multiple
windows okay
well so will it bring up visible web
browser windows plural or what you'll
bring up one each time you run it so if
you use start web session all right so
whether web browser window
well the web browser window is visible
yes yes
maybe we should say with the default
options setting
okay
you
creates
you
okay
you
okay all right so here if I do start web
session all right so I did start web
session there and now wherever that
window was where did that go there we go
so now I did start web session I got
back a web session object
okay so now I can say on that if I now
say web execute there and we'll go there
why does it say not secure oh because I
went to the HTTP version yeah yeah okay
so now I say web execute of page URL
offer comma sake what happened I think
get URL is the current name I'll change
it okay
well given that we're changing do we
want to say URL string for this
shouldn't URL return a URL object if we
want to represent it as a URL object we
can I think it should be easy to make
that change
well do you think it's a good idea
because in these other cases are we
referring to them with symbolic URLs or
do these other ones have you have naked
string URLs in them strings
most of them use strings but there's
only a few that will I think open web
page is the only one that really refers
to it is in Pokhara I think this should
return the URL object okay all right so
so let's look at these ones so what do I
do here if I locate elements if I say
web execute all give me an example
locate elements so I'm sorry what do I
put on the right-hand side here so I
just give me an example a list where
just give me a specific example just
tell me what to type okay so under scope
no this is really an adequate
documentation in fact pathetically
inadequate if I might say so guys come
on
okay you should have documentation here
a section under scope for every single
one of those things up there am I making
sense every single one of these should
have a documentation subsection right
it's done and then tree skip for it yes
yes as a subsection right okay
what the heck is this this is way too
complicated okay whatever okay let's
take a look at this
what are you doing here look at the
mints
well I don't want this I want the thing
I was just doing okay so so this case
alright cuz that's come on let's look at
this case first
alright but that's not what I was asking
for
look at elements thing all right all
right okay okay so this gives this so
that does as you said page opens
successfully where did that message come
from it's that coming from the driver
yes okay and what does tag open web page
what is that coming from because we are
dealing with this open a page function
so we can show page function this says
open page not open web page yeah so
earlier the name was open just so it
needs to be okay so but the tag needs to
be needs to agree with the tags that are
in here right yeah yeah that I'll do
okay all right fine great a problem now
from the from the problem a problem okay
so now here
I don't want to do this I don't want to
do that let me see what it actually
generates okay so okay so hold on so
let's understand what this is doing here
okay so first point is that list we can
remove that list right yeah okay now why
is that returning a list so it's
returning a list of web element objects
because that's the locate elements
that's the result from locate elements
yeah right yeah depending upon the
selector look at a strategy and it can
return multiple of element objects so
that's why it's a list yeah I understand
um click specified
a webpage right or simulator click on a
specified element of a webpage
so it it literally clicks quite similar
I don't know what clique means in them I
okay there is no mouse going click but
there often isn't anyway so who cares
see right okay click an element yeah on
a web page
well click the element click an element
matching the element matching LM is that
correct how do you how is that element
specified so it can either be the
pattern like this selector we just used
or it could be the object or returned
what are you sending me in yeah I just
sent to an example yeah I understand
that it can click the the ID of that
right okay the last one percentage okay
can you please consistently use the
names that we have specified please
let's not have six different versions of
these names running around okay yeah so
is this
% 11 sub 1 or the sisters could be the
whole of % 11 there no % even one like
it is but but why isn't this working
I mean shouldn't click element be able
to it it has to be you should as a
courtesy you should deal with at least
singleton list case if you could deal
with multiple elements that would be
even better answer you can click a
sequence of elements there but whenever
you clicks it goes to a sec other page
so then the second element you will not
be accessible I say okay fine fine okay
so okay fair enough
but then okay but obviously this is a
bug here what if whatever happened here
was a bug right number okay okay okay
click an element on a web page eg a
hyperlink now and that element is
specified okay elements of web pages of
web pages can be specified in any of the
following forms is that true yeah that's
true a previously located element eg
from locate elements
right yeah
you
elements specified using a CSS selector
pattern
okay so a link is it a single link or is
that the first link on the page it'll be
the text of that item so if the items I
understand but if that if it's a single
is it the first one because there might
be 25 different ones with the same you
know what I'm saying
no I'm asking you if you just give a
single no it'll give a list so then okay
all right okay um okay hyperlinks with
text if you call it text you should call
it text not name here right is that
correct I mean with text matching and it
is it a string it's like that right I
think so I thought team was a bit weird
too okay
hyperlinks with text with the specified
text
you
hyperlynx
[Music]
so Reg X's will be nice here but
probably aren't easy to get
swipers do that
why does it have to be in braces here
why do these have to be in braces I
don't think they do do they why would
this boy with these bean braces here
because this is an argument of local
elements I think we could make it work
without braces
it'll be a little bit odd because it's a
rollover all like it's okay okay let's
let's do it okay I think that's
unnecessary okay okay
okay so here
okay hyperlinks with the specified
hyperlinks with text containing
form okay tag
what is a tag name as opposed to just
what is a tag what kind of a tag is that
send HTML tag okay so that that's like
an A or something or a great um
elements with the specified HTML tag
that right
yes oh okay all right so I think we need
to put those three because those are
very common things like the hyperlink
text is super common as a case so I
think we need to put those three top
there these three do you agree is that
reasonable I mean that that's a fairly
simple case the elements with a
specified HTML tag yeah I think those
are easier to use the CSS selector thing
was going to be slightly complicated
yeah I think the CSS selector and next
path are pretty powerful but they are
really hard to use okay which one should
come first the X part I think the X part
should come first
what do you think maybe just because I
understand it a bit better than I
understand the CSS selector there I
don't have a preference
okay so how will we describe the XPath
um elements
on the we could write out on the on the
xml path something like that
you
elements matching the specified CSS
selector pattern is that correct yeah
okay
CSS selector pattern I don't think we
need to say this I mean this is pretty
obvious great so I move the links down
to the related links so I think there's
we could probably remove a lot of those
yeah it's fine
okay okay
web execute allows the following general
commands
okay so let's put the window size which
are rather straightforward let's put the
JavaScript execution at the very end
make sense because it's a really fancy
thing
okay so now yeah that makes sense window
sighs get the current window size as
with height
correct is that correct
yeah thank you set window size set the
current window size okay focus the
webpage on an element what does that
mean so if you have like a text box it
might have focus
why don't we putting that up here that's
along with clique right why isn't that
along with click and type think it makes
sense in that section too
so it's like focus element right instead
of click element that we focus element
it's the same element story
it's like select right it's like put
focus on this element suddenly since to
use one actually this is focus frame I'm
trying to work on it but it is not
actually focusing on the element but
what is it to an eye how do you focus on
an element because there's got to be a
way to focus on that one just as a did
only this function needs some confusion
like I think I need to work on okay so
should we future eyes it for now yeah
focus frame only focus trim accept it so
so shouldn't we have something here that
says focus almond do you know if they
if that's that should be fun okay why
don't you why don't you look at that I
mean I I'm just okay I know one thing
element screenshot is there we can take
a screenshot of a particular element
that is there okay but let's go through
the rest of these okay
so type in element type text into an
element on a web page in input field
okay fine that's fine click an element
that's fine
type in element that's fine okay
submit a form why is the element there
why do you need the element if there's a
form
am i confused can there be multiple
forms even on the form that that space
is defined by the elements so okay
submits a form using the specified
element yeah yeah in other words that's
the submit button eg a submit button
yeah I'm okay hide element what does
that mean making element invisible yes
what does it mean it makes so it hides
it like if you go into chrome and do
hide elements it'll no longer appear on
that web page so just again toggles
visibility okay we're going to put this
way higher than that right the hover so
that should go with click right
great there somewhere
you
since you just told me that it isn't
simulating it's actually clicking it's
actually hovering - yeah I think click
and type should be together but however
so and height should be together as it
is it is an appearance of the element
but hide is something completely
different I mean this is this is an
action that a person could take just
clicking around with their mouse this is
not something a bosom of the mouse can
do yeah cover can launch actions - so
it's a little bit like click and that it
can start things or do things I so but
these things down here I think it's like
element name okay whether the element is
selected whether the element is enabled
okay so let me just understand these
things so the Hyden show are very think
the things you can only do with a web
driver you can not do them yourself on
web page correct yeah great
sometimes the browser might have tools
that will do it it's know I recommend
that we put these two next here after
submit before we go into the hide and
show stuff because there again things
which are closer to the consumer level
maybe all four of those then because
they're kind of informational well the
next two element name an element texts
are both now diving down into the
entrails of the of the page so to speak
I see right
okay
is selected asked whether an element is
enabled
EML tag wasn't that cold element tag
why is it called element name think
we've been calling it tag name so it's
just oh we just changed that to tag down
here yeah so can we make that change um
Element text the text associate text if
any associated with an element so I
assume that that that the text referred
to here for hyperlink will be that same
text that you're searching for in the
hyperlink text
arrow whatever correct
I believe that's the case should can
confirm that but this element text can
be accessed through any of those five
methods not only hyperlink text but any
of those five
I'm sorry what do you mean yeah yeah but
I understand but I'm simply saying that
if you go to a hyperlink and you say
element text of that hyperlink right
then that what you get back you will be
able to feed back into hyperlink text
and it will work true yeah so correct
I'll check that I think so okay fine
executes a string of JavaScript code
specified string of JavaScript code
okay let's move on to the next page here
um so we've done web execute now we did
where but did we do web um start web
session
uhh
[Music]
you
no the web session object isn't used to
control a web browser that represents
creates a web session that can be
controlled that represents a web browser
being controlled by Rob execute is that
right yeah bring up a visible browser
window on the screen okay okay fine we
just went through this
okay web execute web session object
start it style session okay that looks
good all right um okay next on our page
we have did we look at web session
object think only briefly in earlier
meeting okay represents a browser web
browser session okay it's a slightly
strange
his web session someone is asking a
wolfram variant of virtual Dom as in
react my guess is the answer is yes but
can somebody comment on that
I must familiar with virtual Tom we
should ask I'm going to add it as a
speculative keyword here okay you're
gonna find out whether it's actually
correct and why don't you ask yarn who's
an expert on such things but has yarn
ever seen this stuff I don't think so
you should make sure he sees it before
we actually ship this out just to check
that he doesn't have anything you know
there's no oh my gosh okay dollar
current web session um oh that clearly
needs to be that sorry that should be
the
um that's like the very first thing
probably here that's weird
something really weird happened there
something weird happened um follow this
is for you I think I don't think I can
fix this well let's see if I can fix it
yeah that should point $2
I have to say I think the stellar
current web session is a little weird I
mean I guess this is what is this is the
analog of what is that the analog it's
the analog for start external process is
that right to start external what is
what is the analogous thing to start web
session start external what is it to
start external session yeah that's
startin tears I mean um of Python for
example by the way there's some okay so
that's gonna start a Python X so come on
you
what does that mean running on update in
progress
why don't you capture that she's an odd
one I'll take a picture cap take picture
debug it
okay um
you
what is that it is set to none
okay when the session
corresponding to that is closed with the
leat object dollar current web session
is set to none right great
you
you
okay looks reasonable enough okay is
there a guide page for these guys
I'll be fine I don't know I don't think
we found that okay so we're going to get
let's look at the main registration
information first
okay so domain
station why isn't that also completing
this might only Chopin prayer tape okay
so what do we do we say welcome calm
yeah
and we're waiting we're waiting we're
waiting what are we waiting for
should we be giving some kind of fun
okay okay have we gone through
so did we reorganize this you mentioned
a few changes which I relayed to Chris
which were to make the events and
registration dates closer that's up and
then also change the country in state to
entities but this yeah so this has not
been done yet right yeah it's okay so
when is that gonna get done it has been
done it's just not I don't think it's
reflected in the bill yet okay great hi
can you show us on your screen Chris
or could you send me a screen capture I
can share the screen okay go for it
you
you
you
could you it was beautiful it was
perfect
yeah that's great so is are those
official names like admin organization
is that an official term that's that's
the the usual way they've got like one
for you know usually that's kind of how
they they have how they how you know the
people who how they kind of structure
things that admin hold on contact
I don't think events is the right term
for this first thing here and by the way
why does creation date show up in black
here when when all the other keys are
showing up in gray suggests the
structure isn't quite right somehow
um so I mean the thing one wants I guess
okay what I would suggest we do domain
name at the top then registrant okay
okay then I would just have separate
lines for creation date and updated date
as separate things here I think I think
I don't know I mean for some purposes
you don't care about that in for some
purposes that's important um what other
events could there be could there be any
other events um I think I've seen other
ones before but you know I mean
sometimes you can have you have multiple
like updated date size you know going
back somewhat historically I think I
remember seeing stuff like that but okay
let's try something more exotic let's
try let's try for example wolf r-dot am
okay that doesn't look good okay so what
happened there is it
it's generally hard to parse you know
universally all that you know the with
this different TLD you know the the kind
of servers that we're contacting have
different formats and it in this case it
couldn't handle the the dot a.m. format
you know the formats associated with
this new domain so isn't there a general
pattern I mean hasn't somebody compiled
these the patterns of these the problem
is a lot of some of the domains are
different so like okay so so which ones
can we handle so let's try NATO dot int
international event yeah splob okay oh
look wait wait wait wait wait look look
in that address their rule grande roue
grande whatever that looks like it's a
bad character encoding yeah so that's
another problem okay all right let's try
um what are some other ones that we know
um let's try something like it's
probably gonna only work for the
Verisign you know ComNet org i think
it's it's but what is the form of some
of these other ones because obviously i
just drew a solve a response so I don't
quite understand then why we are even
trying to parse it if it's so hopeless
to parse it's not you know there's been
other solutions you know is it's
basically this is just a subset of what
what what has been done you know there's
then what we should do instead of just
returning an error like this
presumably what we should do okay so
what you're telling me is this is the
raw string so if you scroll down here is
it the case that okay registry response
register response what does that mean
what is
what do those mean well it was it was
unable to find a referral to contact the
registry so it just it gives up at only
trying to resolve you know what what
registry to go to to talk about you know
in a toad audience so the registry that
handles the dot int it couldn't resolve
that well how does it know I mean if it
can't resolve the registry okay what did
it do to get this response the registry
resolved a response what does that
actually mean here it talks to to uh I
Anna dot who is I know who is Diana dot
organ and they've they've got a
directory set up for you know every TLD
here's the registry you go to and that's
that this is basically what it's doing
and okay so what okay so wait a minute
so then why was it not able to figure
out what who is server it went to so it
has a secondary list of servers from
that it gets from the first server so if
one of those doesn't come back correctly
I'm not quite sure why it didn't in this
case okay but but so a couple of
questions right so am I to understand
okay so in terms of what's here like
these address lines etc is that the same
form as a Verisign one or is that
different I I think you know uh I think
you know generally the you know Verisign
you know they'll be different I think
and yeah have we looked as somebody you
know curated all of these I mean that
there aren't that many TLDs yes in that
you know well I mean it's not just TLDs
it's kind of like you know it's it's per
it's not just TLDs it's like when you
have registries but the annular
registrar's and they've got their own
you know oh you know every who is server
you talk to you it's gonna have a
different format and that that has been
compiled and it's but it's a it's called
Ruby who had
who is and that's been compiled and then
then there's there's others that kind of
like Python who is an existing solution
and they've got you know they've got
more sophisticated parsing abilities and
they get a higher percentage of of
matches generally from different TLDs
and they just they don't have a
differentiated for her who is server
they they just try to grab what they can
and so I'm testing solutions are namely
I think this is gonna require more
thought I I'm not sure I mean one of the
things that's clearly useful for example
finding out what country okay so let's
we can go back let me go back to my
screen if you can unshare um so I mean a
typical thing somebody's going to want
to do
is to find
country I mean this you know my most
obvious question would be what country
is the sin
right but now in the way you've got the
set up right now I would have to go
registrant country like that is that
correct no how does that work it would
be keys of the return of domain
registration information
like this why is it taking so okay and
that you've now canonicalized that to
actually be at least for these Verisign
ones to actually be yeah
okay so I mean
oh boy I mean to me the most obvious
things people are gonna want are the
country the organization
those kinds of things
you
I mean this kind of stuff like the abuse
contact phone number those are pretty
obscure
you
well now why is the expiration date so
that's not part of the creation date and
the updated date are not are not
connected to the expiration date
I think that's the time yeah I think
that it that that's the expiration date
for the registry you know they don't
expire but they I think at some point
they've got they've got to renew some
kind of agreement they have with ayan or
something but that's that's particular
okay so that that's of the registry
that's not the date when this
registration of this domain name will
expire is that correct I think so I
think that's right what does it mean
language
well you know if it was if it was if it
was able to handle more than the
Verisign things you could have varying
languages I think we've got more to
understand here Garrett have you dug
into this to try to understand but I
mean also have we talked to the sysadmin
group about this since they live this
stuff all the time I think we talked to
them about it a little bit we had a
meeting scheduled for it but I am not
quite sure what happened I think they
may have looked over it I guess we have
we actually don't know so look the
people who should be involved are Eric
act who deals with domain names for us
right and who will have seen endless
ones of these and I don't know who
Warren would suggest insisted men who
seen endless ones of these yeah it
sounds like he's the right person yeah I
think we did tasks
Eric tracked about it and he seemed okay
with it
is that right Carla that doesn't seem
convincing then he wasn't asked
correctly um all right this needs more
work I think we're not going to get this
nailed right now what should we do we
could put this function in but not
document it is my suggestion for this
version but we're not gonna get this
done this quickly
that sound okay I mean it's I think the
yeah we just need to we need yeah maybe
maybe you can get me maybe you should do
a meeting with those people first with
the question of what do people actually
want to get out of these this these
results and how can we do better at
globally making it work and if it isn't
going to work globally we need a better
way to return things for example we need
a raw return raw string element to this
making sense that would then get filled
in and these other elements would not be
just be missing not available
but that makes sense rather than giving
just an error condition there do you get
what I'm saying so no that's it's a data
set with the raw string in it that makes
sense to me that seemed reasonable so
having a data set of the you know
whatever the raw responds I know I'm not
quite there I'm saying I'm saying
include the raw response in the data set
if you cannot parse the raw response
then the only thing in the data set that
will be interesting is the raw response
and all the other things will say
missing not available
did you get what I'm saying okay that
will be what I would do rather than
having something where it's an error
condition and you've got to go you know
track that down all right so look for
this version let's not document this we
can put it in but don't document it
alright very quick look at external
function now if we could um and then
piccalo you you're remembering we have
not knitted the the guide pages for
those for those web things
okay so did you
okay so external function does this work
no it's pretty not gonna work for me
because I've got some busted
configuration here great mmm that one
did work okay
so then that is a Python function that
can presumably do absolute values oh
great
what's that also this is this is unclear
what why is this saying it doesn't have
an argument structure here you know
something's something weird is happening
because those aren't the same attributes
that I did expect to get back all right
I can okay so something's wrong yeah
okay the lambda okay this is the lambda
no this isn't a lambda this is what is
this so there's a few different ways you
might want to specify a lambda so you
could do a lambda I wish you mean like
an actual Python lambda like that you
know where you may want to use it to
evaluate or you could say if we want
someone to be able to enter a definition
into a function kind of that I do think
that this is a very big this is a
graphic-design thing I would recommend
we reduce the size of that icon a bit
it's kind of dominating the whole page
that's a collar that says that's
something you could talk to a graphic
design about please okay I'm sorry but
so what is this I don't I don't know
what so that was meant for a little bit
more forth on the external function
repository if we wanted to add it into
there then people may want to add their
own kind of definitions for functions
and if you were wanted something like
that
then the easiest way to do it is to have
the definition as part of as a way to
specify the external function you want
to have so this is trying to that method
I am totally confused I'm sorry I'm
totally confused why so if I want to
send this to someone on another computer
just the code of this but but you could
send the länder as well great so it's a
worry why I'm confused if if this is
defining a function that function will
be permanent in that Python session
correct correct okay so that's a
completely different thing here that
we're doing I would recommend what the
heck is this so what happened here
that's like I've been okay yet I think
that one's resolved but we're working on
updating that okay I think I'm gonna
have to look at this one more time and
what happened to the stuff that
Christopher was doing with library link
an external function is that in any way
making it I don't think the C version is
that far along okay um
someone's asking his with external
functions work with Python 3 and the TK
GUI plotting operations I don't know
what'll work with Python 3 yeah it
should work with both 2 and 3 I don't
know about the plotting operation
specifically but it should work as long
as it works with any functions so
someone was asking if you have a Python
function like range of 10,000 will it
convert well I can't run anything here
but well I mean that that's already
working that you can just say um
that's I don't know Python so I mean if
I say external evaluate how is this I
mean the question is is this converting
to text or is it how does this work they
use the same name and that cute um how
is this doing the transfer is it with
wxf or what so the transfer back is wxf
and then it gets converted into Wolfram
language so there's a serialize er that
durian worked on that's part of Wolfram
python client libraries and that kind of
interprets what the type is on the
Python side there is conversion from its
internal data structures to wxf is that
correct yeah exactly
and so wxf is the format that gets moved
over so it's not text in any way great
so then the question here okay so
somebody's commenting non efficient
memory sharing is the biggest problem
here so what will happen with with the
library link stuff doesn't that allow
memory sharing so that would be more for
the C function case I don't know if we
do any kind of library link doctor
connection with Python though it might
if you know we were to connect it into
the same process you might be able to
use shared memory and get it to go a
little bit faster but at the same time
that opens you up to you know just crash
but that's okay if you're if you're
running it as a headless you know it's
just a separate process fine
yeah um it'd also be remarkably tricky
because you'd have to that you normally
built those into the same executable so
you'd have to do things like wording
there all kinds of comments him we're
probably not the right team to be
talking about these comments about
Apache arrow data frame support and okay
so the complaint is that running
external evaluate with range of 10,000
the climbers take
this claims to take a second so what's
it doing anybody know what's that doing
is that a question for Fedor Ian that's
probably for Dorian okay so yes
yeah is that it doesn't know the type of
every element so it might be converting
each one back individually that seems
very bizarre why don't we ask Dorian
Carla can you ask Dorian please yes I
mean maybe it's just a bug of some kind
cuz it shouldn't it should be blindingly
fast it's just converting a native
Python list thingy into our into a wxf
list
um someone is claiming that it's
converting to JSON but I don't think
that's the case someone is asking for
seamless pandas I think in the old
version it was Jason I think in it's
been updated to you oh okay so maybe in
version 12 Oh curse that that's probably
different so this is running in 11.3 so
if I try running it here it'll probably
fail completely
because yeah this what just happened
there what happened there well you have
it suppressed so no I understand I
understand you think it might be so
something is wrong here right so this is
much slower than 11:3 making sense
so something is wrong wrong wrong group
of people here to address this yeah it's
the wrong group oh it's zero origin can
see that it's a mistake um anyway um
okay
all right I think we have to wrap this
up so we've still got external function
we still have a little bit to look at
there um we've got nothing to do and for
goodness sake let's figure out what's
happening with the speed problem
okay and if you can let me know Carlo
what you
about that okay yeah I'll talk to Dorian
okay for those who are on the livestream
thanks for participating in this we are
actually going straight to another
livestream about machine learning we are
talking about unsupervised machine
learning functions like anomaly
detection and so on so I hope to see and
see you there